[SPEAKER_01]: Barn Man.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sir Bard.
[SPEAKER_04]: Morning of the third of Wealsun as the hour approaches eight o'clock.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, I walk up to Gouge and kind of appear.
[SPEAKER_06]: I had been invisible.
[SPEAKER_06]: So where we had barred the door after we snaked a stone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, you couldn't give me like 20 more minutes to get another spell slot?
[SPEAKER_06]: The ghost is gone.
[SPEAKER_06]: I couldn't see it anchored.
[SPEAKER_06]: So at least where it was, I don't know if there'll be another ship coming in.
[SPEAKER_06]: The hobgoblins, the demonstrations on the front of the gate, they've moved away since dawn.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where the hell did you go?
[SPEAKER_06]: I snuck around.
[SPEAKER_06]: I cast invisibility on myself and I just snuck around to kind of see what was up.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nobody can get down here because we barred that door when we came back into that inner sanctum up there.
[SPEAKER_06]: So the hobgoblins are still there.
[SPEAKER_06]: The troops are no longer demonstrated so they've probably gone back to the garrison.
[SPEAKER_06]: I did go look through that other door that we did not check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Remember that?
[SPEAKER_06]: The bar door or the bars?
[SPEAKER_06]: The bars.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that part was open.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, it's open.
[SPEAKER_06]: There was probably, there were racks that were all empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: Probably thousands of barrel storage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's when I figured why the bars were there.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was probably where they kept them.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, but when I went further down, there was another door that was barred that I could see like a small little beach or a little beach area.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that's a secret entrance.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I saw footprints on the sand, but I couldn't get through it because it was locked.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have keys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got lockpicks.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I'm saying is that I saw footprints.
[SPEAKER_06]: In the 30 minutes, if Toli lived, I didn't see- They would have been wet.
[SPEAKER_02]: They would have been dripping.
[SPEAKER_06]: I looked for that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I looked for wet footprints on the pavement and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know that we know all of the secret passages.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just know that I saw the footprints on the sand.
[SPEAKER_06]: The ghost is gone.
[SPEAKER_06]: The troops have moved back, but that's not a surprise that the troops moved back to the garrison.
[SPEAKER_06]: The hobgoblins are still outside of that inner sanctum where we snuck by all of them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where we would have to, you know, go out there and kill the ones that were kind of on guard and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't want to try to sneak past the hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_06]: I could do it again, but I would have to rest.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know that we're gonna see the smaller boat come back in if the ghost is gone.
[SPEAKER_06]: If the ghost is gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: When we saw the ghost, that was night.
[SPEAKER_04]: That was the beginning of the evening.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, round 11.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think the ghost in this whole thing is only done under the cover of night?
[SPEAKER_02]: That they're not doing it out in the open in case there's other merchant ships or something that would see this?
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's buying us time to get ready and set up for them to come get the rest?
[SPEAKER_06]: If that's the case, then Toli maybe didn't swim out to the ghost.
[SPEAKER_06]: The minute that we dropped that... Fairfield.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fairfield, sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, I don't think he'd swim that fuckin' far.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's a pirate.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's a sailor.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then with the sharks, I don't know how well he was protected from us.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, but once we dropped that stuff in the water...
[SPEAKER_06]: They ate a Toli.
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know, but- He killed all of those sahaugin like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if the tide rushes that stuff out- Unless he was watching.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he probably figured.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: We actually, I mean, like we told him we were going to try to go take the barrels and stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I'm not saying he did.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm just saying that-
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: If, I mean, if there's a skiff coming in, I gotta go rest now so that I can try to get some spells back, but if there's a skiff coming in, great.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't, in other words, I don't think, I couldn't find any way, and I saw some footprints on the beach when I looked through that one, like on the small, a small little beach.
[SPEAKER_06]: So if he went through that and he locked the door behind him,
[SPEAKER_02]: But you didn't have any keys or anything, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you stripped them down and shit?
[SPEAKER_02]: I checked as best I could.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where does he actually reside?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where is he a lord of?
[SPEAKER_02]: This isn't the only place, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is he the keeper of the small island?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, Fairwood Island is a large Adirondi.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's got an entire island that is his domain.
[SPEAKER_06]: Remember, they rotate between the princes.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is a rotation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, this is a rotation, so each lord takes a rotation.
[SPEAKER_06]: But remember, he had said, he voluntarily said that he's been taking off for a while.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's got his own storage staff for this ship.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so if the Tollies came, they're actually a little bit late to the game, because if the Tollies came to take barrels,
[SPEAKER_06]: And it was during the fog.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was during the fog.
[SPEAKER_06]: He said he's been taking barrels for the last month.
[SPEAKER_06]: Easily.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or maybe longer.
[SPEAKER_06]: Eric, come with me.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, of those thousands of barrels that were off the rack, I don't know how much of those, but totally.
[SPEAKER_04]: With the sahaugin dead, there's no reason not to signal.
[SPEAKER_04]: Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can do that from the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now the question is, have you gotten enough of the island safe to be able to do this?
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't know how this stuff works, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: But whatever the case, you know that there are a lot of dead people out this way, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm just saying.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like... How far away is the shark from land that I'm on right now?
[SPEAKER_03]: 50 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: 50 feet from land.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was like, if we could...
[SPEAKER_03]: Signaling is big, for sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: If we can get Jude or Folsom up there to signal back.
[SPEAKER_03]: But if we need to get off of the island quickly, could this shark hold the party?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And there's tents out there?
[SPEAKER_03]: There are tents down below.
[SPEAKER_03]: Down below where, um, by the shoreline, correct?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, by the docks.
[SPEAKER_03]: By the docks, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two.
[SPEAKER_03]: How big are these tents?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I remember from when I was down there?
[SPEAKER_03]: They're decent, actually.
[SPEAKER_04]: The hobgoblin equipment's pretty good.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if they took a long rest, if they decided to rest, could I...
[SPEAKER_03]: Makeshift a little sailboat onto this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Possibly, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Very makeshift, hopefully to see a merchant ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that what you would want to do is, so the shark is really heavy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think basically what you would do is you would ride out with the
[SPEAKER_04]: The Tide.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you could, you know, paddle it in that direction because the tide will move in and out of this place big time.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you could probably ride this thing out of the deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: But, I mean...
[SPEAKER_04]: The shark is one thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: You could probably take the docks, tear them up, and make a raft out of it.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you want to make a little makeshift craft.
[SPEAKER_03]: That'd probably take just as long as trying to get stuff on the shark too.
[SPEAKER_03]: Relatively.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, I'll start heading back.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna leave the shark, and I'm gonna start heading back up my rope, or swimming back to shore, whatever's quicker.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm gonna swim ashore, I'm gonna start crafting around a little bit, maybe tearing up some tents.
[SPEAKER_03]: Look at pieces, see what we got while they're doing this thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, alright.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's make a survival roll.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: We could take the beacon tower and we could signal and say that we have possession of the barrels, there's no sahaugin, or we've repelled the sahaugin, bring reinforcements.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if they bring reinforcements, I think that his force, unless, if he was here, we're gonna take him.
[SPEAKER_06]: If he's not here, but we would need to get the main beacon tower to communicate to Monmurg, I think it's in the citadel, it's in the castle.
[SPEAKER_06]: So, I think that maybe that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Now, if you wanted to do that since it's been an hour and not wait four more hours for me, I can go with you guys and I can use my wand and I still have a bunch of, I still have four first-level spells and I have a shit ton of my cantrips.
[SPEAKER_06]: You want me to continue this conversation over there?
[SPEAKER_06]: I can tell what's going on while they're doing this?
[SPEAKER_06]: My magic stick is, uh, I got like, uh,
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you go down with Merrick to the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we're sailing in the shop.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, but close.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is going to save us more time.
[SPEAKER_03]: With these docks, with these tents, I can makeshift a raft, and I can sail us back to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can get some barrels on here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can report to Lord Jamis what we found.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can get Paul Rivera to safety.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can refigure our stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: How long do you think it would take to sail, roughly, if I did that?
[SPEAKER_04]: It would be about a five-hour trip.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five-hour trip, but also maybe a chance to run into a merchant ship or something that could help us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, with the blockade, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that the best thing that you would do is run into a patrol, and actually if you signaled,
[SPEAKER_04]: From the Inner Sanctum and said, we're on our way, they would meet you out there.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if you had a barrel or two of this shit...
[SPEAKER_04]: You could be, make sure that no sahaugin, basically you could distribute this stuff and make sure that the straight was safe.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's the main thing you're worried about is that you did dump a barrel into this water, but it might just be in this area.
[SPEAKER_04]: But if you're like taking the boat out and like chumming the shit, none of the sahaugin are gonna come near you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I need you to talk to Jude.
[SPEAKER_03]: How long has he rested?
[SPEAKER_03]: An hour.
[SPEAKER_03]: You need to charm someone.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I don't have any charm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, he doesn't have any of that?
[SPEAKER_03]: He has to do a long rest to get that going.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need you to use all the charisma you have.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need you to get Jude back up into the sanctum to signal we're on our way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Watch the waves.
[SPEAKER_03]: No more detail than that.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to get G. You want me to use as much criticism as I can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or if you feel comfortable to signal, we need to get signal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go back to the same time.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm an expert at signaling.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to signal on our way, watch the waves.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then try to spell out my name.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to just...
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to be here crafting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, and I'm going to the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_03]: Either you or one of them was...
[SPEAKER_03]: Inner Sanctum, is that where all the hobgoblins and stuff were?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, that was where you guys caught the Toli Assassins and you caught Lord's Fairfield.
[SPEAKER_04]: You were going to the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_04]: It was barred off, and supposedly Jude just said it was still secure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, you're going to the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you do that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you walk away.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just kind of do my own thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you kind of sneak away, and walk back up the pierce, back to where the inner sanctum is.
[SPEAKER_04]: This takes you maybe about 15 minutes, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: You go up into the area, it's still secure, body of the hobgoblin, body of the Toli guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you go to the window, and there is the signal lantern that you want to use.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so what do you signal to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_05]: I signal...
[SPEAKER_05]: On our way, watch the waves, and then spell out Merrick's name.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you go back?
[SPEAKER_05]: I just kind of wander back and see, kind of check the Toli again.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Actually, can I check this Toli to see if there's any markings on it?
[SPEAKER_04]: There's none.
[SPEAKER_04]: He has perfect skin.
[SPEAKER_04]: Obviously didn't want to mar it with a tattoo or anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, with Jude, I was just double checking because he was curious or interested.
[SPEAKER_05]: I looked out for Jude, so maybe he can...
[SPEAKER_01]: I went out and that went through some caverns.
[SPEAKER_06]: There was a whole bunch of like areas for barrels that were empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: The shelves were empty.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it was the barrels about the same size.
[SPEAKER_06]: But then there was another, before you went to the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: Limited well of stamina, I can do that and get it back on a short rest so I could have used that because that would have been a die ten.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: During battle.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, you should have done it when you were battling the hog and going,
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Second wind.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, you got a second wind.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's why you got the fighter.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gotta remember that's an important gentleman.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's really important.
[SPEAKER_06]: Alright, so what do we want to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: You asking me?
[SPEAKER_06]: What I mean is, are we still going?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm good to go.
[SPEAKER_06]: Are we good to go?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys ready?
[SPEAKER_06]: What do you guys got going?
[SPEAKER_06]: Are you good to go?
[SPEAKER_04]: These guys aren't here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, they're not.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where'd they go?
[SPEAKER_04]: You actually see Merrick down in the dock areas ripping stuff up and taking tents and nailing stuff together.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like making a fortification?
[SPEAKER_06]: What's he doing?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: What are you doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you going to sail this shark out of here?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm working.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is he really trying to like turn this thing into a Captain Nemo?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, the shark's out of the picture.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sark already sank.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, well, I need to know if I get to rest for four hours or if you guys want to act.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can just start resting and we'll see what happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to go down and see what they're doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right, so I'll start my four-hour rest.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know if I'm going to make it four hours, but I'll start to meditate.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so if the boat, the skiff, was going to come back from the other boat by now, it wouldn't come back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And obviously the sea ghost is gone, so where that skiff is, who knows, but it's not going back and forth between there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you walk down to Merrick who is pulling up lumber from the docks and kind of putting together some structure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you got going on here?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm meditating, so I'm not there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
I'm there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm there now.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to walk down too?
[SPEAKER_00]: What the hell is this?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go ahead and rest if I can rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh yeah, because if you can rest longer.
[SPEAKER_06]: If I can rest longer, I'll rest longer.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You keep going.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_03]: I created, I'm making a makeshift raft.
[SPEAKER_03]: We are going to sail around the platoon.
[SPEAKER_03]: I sent Folsom up to the inner sanctum.
[SPEAKER_03]: These signal back to our men, watch the waves, we're on our way.
[SPEAKER_03]: A platoon is going to meet us, and we're going to get back to Monmurg by tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Easily.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or tonight, if possible.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roughly a five hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what's the, uh, don't worry about the sharks?
[SPEAKER_03]: Nope, we're going to take enough barrel to keep us off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Keep the sharks off, and we're going to get back to safety.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to get his ass back, because that's our fucking job.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: My job's on the line.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't give two shits of what's going on with the rest of the island.
[SPEAKER_03]: This whole scenario's fucked.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's hogging our backs.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to get to safety.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to go back and we need to figure out a better plan.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, that's what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: We send a dead call and bring back information on what's going on here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think we have a lot of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we got that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's almost died, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want my ass on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is he back?
[SPEAKER_03]: Did he make it back or is he still up there?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm helping.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's helping you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsom, you already signaled him.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, no.
[SPEAKER_05]: So they expect us now.
[SPEAKER_05]: They do expect us.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we better start fucking moving.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: In a little bit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let the elf meditate.
[SPEAKER_03]: He seems like he's vibing out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: That was vibing it out.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, this is as much as your responsibility is to put on my shoulders as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I know these waves like the back of my hand.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know the exact right time that's going to get us over there in the quickest amount of fashion.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get on the boat and we're going to try to get back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Getting out of here would be the best thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we've got the barrels and... We've got barrels to keep the hogging off of.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like Jude's afraid of if they...
[SPEAKER_02]: Mount some type of thing and fair ones there and get his guys work fucked.
[SPEAKER_02]: So getting out of here would be great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe we can just carry the elf, put him on the raft so we don't interrupt him and just go, and that way he can't tell us that it's not gonna happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, take the carpet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take him up on the carpet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I do want the elf to be in his best form, because if we run into a holy boat, if we run into anything that's gonna hinder us, a good fireball could go a long way.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not listening.
[SPEAKER_06]: You're humming louder.
[SPEAKER_06]: Keep meditating.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're just carrying you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Keep meditating.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, if you want to help out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I feel fine, so, I'll- Alright, well, you know what?
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought this plan would be a lot worse than it actually sounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give us some credit.
[SPEAKER_05]: I said, okay, I'm just correcting myself, okay?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm just a bard.
[SPEAKER_05]: I play the fucking flute.
The fife.
The fife, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fief.
[SPEAKER_00]: The bard that plays the fife.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why do you let the bard hold the prisoner?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it was so entertaining.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was pretty... That was really...
[SPEAKER_06]: It's all...
[SPEAKER_06]: Sorry, can you help us?
[SPEAKER_06]: Guards, it's Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've been held against my will.
[SPEAKER_00]: I told you!
[SPEAKER_00]: I told you at the very beginning of the night.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking that you guys were going to ride the shark out.
[SPEAKER_03]: That was my first point.
[SPEAKER_00]: According to the rest of my survival instinct and ranger intuition.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was thinking we were going to pull a Jack Sparrow and hold the boat under as we walk across the sea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or we were going to gun the shark, wear it kind of like Chinese dragon thing, and sneak him on the beach.
[SPEAKER_03]: These were all discussed.
[SPEAKER_03]: These were all discussed, literally.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, we did discuss them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gotta get back to work.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a long walk.
[SPEAKER_06]: So he's breaking up the quay.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so basically you guys spend two hours creating this raft, and you're okay with this plan?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, it's just as much.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's probably more in charge than I am.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I've got no leadership role amongst the military men here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm looking up for our best interests when it came to Lord Jamis, our mission.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have the information, and we got Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_03]: As I said, I have this hired axe, so I'm not his...
[SPEAKER_03]: Your safety, information.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's the information?
[SPEAKER_03]: Everything we witnessed is the information.
[SPEAKER_03]: Recounting our story.
[SPEAKER_03]: And whatever information you have.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that information, you do it with what you will.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to report to Jamis.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not sure your uncle, I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's just say he didn't really worry about this and he was not concerned.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jamis was.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jamis was correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's who we need to report to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I understand.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So two hours later, you guys have a raft.
[SPEAKER_04]: Huzzah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can we carry the elf or do we leave him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, two or three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_04]: So it's been three total?
[SPEAKER_04]: Three hours total, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Only two for him recovering because he was out wandering around.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need two more or I got nothing.
[SPEAKER_04]: So how many barrels do you want to take with you?
[SPEAKER_03]: How many will go?
[SPEAKER_03]: How big did I make this raft?
[SPEAKER_04]: This raft is going to have to carry, you know, six people.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't want to overburden it too much.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think you would take more than four.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're taking four.
[SPEAKER_01]: How long is a long rest?
[SPEAKER_01]: How long does a long rest?
[SPEAKER_04]: Eight hours.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, we'll take four for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That leaves 21.
[SPEAKER_02]: With my survival check, can you hide them?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not hide them, but what's the best...
[SPEAKER_03]: To go home, tide-wise, what's the best time to get moving?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's passed.
[SPEAKER_04]: But on the shark, you would be able to do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: But on the raft, you could probably paddle out of this thing and make it to Monmurg before Nightfall, definitely.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if somebody sees you, and that's actually what you're really hoping, they see you and they send a ship out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, do we wait for the elf or do we just start moving?
[SPEAKER_03]: Like I said, just pick up the rug on the elf and scoot him on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are we allowed him to do that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or does he need to be stationed?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, he's only trancing, so really what happens is he basically can be led down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: To the raft!
[SPEAKER_00]: So we have... Sliwasa!
[SPEAKER_06]: I've already missed one opportunity to trance.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is he walking around or is he sitting cross-legged?
[SPEAKER_06]: If you want to guide me or drag him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's sitting cross-legged.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you guys want to, you guys can pick him up.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the strength?
[SPEAKER_02]: I got 18.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not that heavy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You carry him down to the raft?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I don't fuck with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't say anything like I normally would.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gentle for you when crickets his ears.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't whisper in my ear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus, how are you feeling?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I'm gonna continue to- I'm gonna get on the raft, but I'll continue to rest in this area.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have to- I just need- I don't have to necessarily trance, do I?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to sleep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need like eight hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: For a long raft.
[SPEAKER_01]: I get like four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, then I'm gonna get on the raft to sleep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can stay awake.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsom.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: We take off.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you guys paddle?
[SPEAKER_03]: And I direct.
[SPEAKER_06]: Paul can paddle.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I can paddle.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paddle as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm going to try to direct.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm thinking the raft is kind of just floating piece of wood.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's better than that, actually.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tent.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's called a sail.
[SPEAKER_03]: Did you call it a tent?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's where I come from, Navy-wise, it's called the tent.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's naval talk.
[SPEAKER_00]: No way you called it a tent.
[SPEAKER_04]: A tent is a makeshift sail.
[SPEAKER_00]: You could have said makeshift sail.
[SPEAKER_01]: These are no longer tents.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're called sails.
[SPEAKER_00]: You take the 10 thing, and you turn it, and the wind...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll be directing, correcting the scale.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wake me up if you need me, otherwise I'm gonna sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Folsom, you signaled our guys on the other end.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that what you did?
[SPEAKER_02]: In Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_02]: You signaled Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: That we were... Oh, so wait, you got... You signaled all the way to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm crazy like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dang.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did he signal Monmurg or did he signal the other guy?
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you signal Apollo?
[SPEAKER_04]: He signaled Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, you signaled all the way to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_04]: From the Inner Sanctum.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm good at what I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, from the Inner Sanctum of... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just took a stroll up there by myself and I signaled to them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Watch the waters.
[SPEAKER_05]: I feel like that's too convenient.
[SPEAKER_05]: How far is that?
[SPEAKER_04]: I signaled Merrick's name.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's five miles.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh shit, that's it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Monmurg is five miles away.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh shit, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right across the bay.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're right there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's like you can see him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Toli is way down below.
[SPEAKER_02]: Toli is like 100 miles.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we could get there and they could theoretically send more ships out with those barrels.
[SPEAKER_06]: Tell them where the fucking barrels are.
[SPEAKER_06]: We could probably take the island before the next dawn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wake me up if you need me, otherwise I'm asleep.
[SPEAKER_01]: I might jump off and jump back on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so we start sailing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm gonna rest.
[SPEAKER_06]: If I get two more hours, then if shit hits the fan, wake me up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys paddle out into, out through the caves.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dead sahaugin all over the place.
[SPEAKER_04]: What are you hitting here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Crickets.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can somebody grab a sahaugin body for me?
[SPEAKER_03]: Why?
[SPEAKER_04]: Nobody wants to know that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Actually, can I grab a sahaugin body?
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait a minute.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sahaugin are back.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're floating.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm willing to watch an elf fuck a dead sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was thinking more about skein it, using its femur bone as a wand base.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, my bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be fair, that is what you applied.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aren't all the elves next to you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't apply having sex with a dead sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Only as a giraffe.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm like this, I'm all like, grab a dead sahaugin body for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: Dude, you're all good.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're grabbing a sahaugin body for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: That is a good idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I grab a sahaugin and pull it up?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just rope it and let it float behind me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or whatever, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I want to bring it back and show Jamis this is real.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is happening.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you guys, it takes you about 15 minutes to float out of the cave mouth, and then Merrick is able to get the sail going, and even though the boat is slow, you make progress.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're moving around one mile per hour as you move that into the channel.
[SPEAKER_04]: So five hours?
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll initiative.
[SPEAKER_00]: The ghost comes flying out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's right behind you.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's right behind me.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, you move out.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to chump the stuff or do you want to just keep it right now the way it is?
[SPEAKER_03]: I would like to open a barrel, handfuls, every few, I don't know,
[SPEAKER_03]: Every five minutes?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, every five minutes, ten minutes or so, sprinkling some out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Throw some out into the ocean.
[SPEAKER_03]: Throw some in a pouch.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're gonna keep some of this shit, not in a barrel.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'm gonna do a line.
[SPEAKER_03]: Doing some lines, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: This yellow stuff, it's sulfury.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fuck this red eye.
[SPEAKER_02]: This shit's gold.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so anyway.
[SPEAKER_04]: Again, it is explosive.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you come out that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: In about an hour, you have navigated around Helm Island, from here to here, and are on your way to Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Another hour goes by.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is probably around 10 a.m. in the morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: Have I had my four hours?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, you have.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see three co-sairs heading from the city towards where you are.
[SPEAKER_04]: Aha.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the one to signal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, did you signal the keep?
[SPEAKER_06]: Did you let them at least know what the fuck was going on?
[SPEAKER_06]: You mean the other tower?
[SPEAKER_02]: The other tower, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: That would be him.
[SPEAKER_05]: We'll let them know that we're in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_05]: Alright, so, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just a bunker down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, just curious.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, another 30 minutes and one of the co-seirs pulls up to your thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to make sure that I have a pocket full of that yellow stuff, like in a pile, in a little bag, because I want to study it for later myself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so Jude, you go up to get a pocket full of that stuff and you take it and put it in your pouch?
[SPEAKER_03]: Pocket full of shoes.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I start to drag in the body they've been towing behind and I start to look and see, is there any magical properties that I can get from a femur bone?
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I mean, obviously you'd want to use the sahaugin's gills to make potions of water breathing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I thought that you guys see me drag that carcass up onto the rack while you guys are talking to the Corsair people and I start
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I show the Corsair, the Sahaugin body, and be like, they're back.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's real.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I mean, you guys, basically, these guys pick you up.
[SPEAKER_04]: The six of you are taken on board.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick explains the Sahaugin attack and then talks about, do you want to say anything about the powder?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: To who?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're gonna let this whole secret out to everybody?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not gonna do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna say that for Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you get loaded, the captain takes you, basically says... Well, are we gonna go back to the island?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or are we going back to Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going back to Monmurg, I'm telling Jamis, then we're gonna go back with the bigger fleet.
[SPEAKER_06]: But we got three Corsair ships.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two keep going.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: But basically, do you want to tell the captain there's an all clear?
[SPEAKER_04]: But that you want to go back and talk to Jamis?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I do.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's an all clear.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to take some of the- Wait, there's an all clear?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, but there's hobgoblins on the helm.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is that an all clear?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: What he's saying is, we get to the island and kind of give the information to everybody.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's basically saying, you can go to the island.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's Sahaugin Free, but there's hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_06]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_06]: But there's hobgoblins there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or if you want to, you can get all those Corsairs and turn around and go back to the city and then report to Jamis.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are Corsairs loaded with Marines, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I want to tell them, send some support to, where did we start out here?
[SPEAKER_03]: Send some here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, definitely one here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I don't know anything about over here what's going on.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, and then reinforce the barracks is where we were.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to reinforce that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Probably what's more important is you want ships there to make sure nobody goes back in that case.
[SPEAKER_06]: And the other 20, if there were 25 barrels and we could only take four, the other 21,
[SPEAKER_06]: This is only good for a couple days.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, but the problem is this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not everybody knows about the cave.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, right, exactly.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you could say post off of the northwestern edge or northeastern edge.
[SPEAKER_06]: But what I'm also, what I'm suggesting is that if nobody knows to chum the damn water in two more days...
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I think we can get back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Send the two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, that's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're only five miles away.
[SPEAKER_02]: They need to get back there before night.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: I do want to take all the barrels with us though.
[SPEAKER_03]: All four.
[SPEAKER_03]: At least two.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, all four of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: All four of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: Should we not send the other Coseras with them just in case?
[SPEAKER_03]: Actually, I don't want to tell them what it is, so I'm going to take them all four of them back.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, but you could just tell somebody, give them an order, or you could have him give them an order to sprinkle some of this.
[SPEAKER_06]: In the water, in the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: True.
[SPEAKER_01]: One barrel is supposed to take care of the whole island.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's what they said.
[SPEAKER_01]: One barrel, and we've already put two barrels out there.
[SPEAKER_06]: So you can tell them, like, tomorrow or the next day.
[SPEAKER_01]: We put two barrels worth out there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we'll be back in the next day, though.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll be back in the next day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dad would say this is a shark poison.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you could just say it's a shark poison.
[SPEAKER_02]: See, look what just came out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Throw this stuff out and we'll keep them away.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't even have to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't even have to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: We put two barrels out.
[SPEAKER_01]: We sprinkled one already in the bay here, and then you sprinkled one all the way out as we went along.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's two whole barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's probably more than enough for at least to get us a whole day and a half or two days or something at least.
[SPEAKER_03]: If we believe what they said, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we send the two there.
[SPEAKER_01]: We send some reinforcements here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Within a day, we go back.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or we send somebody... Or at least somebody back with those other barrels.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't even have to go back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody to block this off here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't even tell them what they have to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: We just have to say, block this area here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somebody to reinforce that gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: They move up to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to keep the girls from coming back at night in Miami.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where we left from, we need to get a Kosair back in there to protect the docking area where we left from.
[SPEAKER_01]: But they don't know where that is.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we'll just come to block this area here, the back side of this.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't know where that is.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I can tell where it is because I came from there.
[SPEAKER_03]: They know the waters as well as I do.
[SPEAKER_03]: But it's a state secret.
[SPEAKER_03]: State secret.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I'm not telling them this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, we're going to block off this, and we're going to send a Cossaire here to support our troops here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Block there, block there, and we're going to sail back with the four.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then once we rest, we can turn around and be back within a day.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's only five miles away.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm fuckin' fine enough to go back out with them.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you guys are comin' back.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're comin' with me and we're gonna tell Jamis everything's gone down.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't both need to say it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, we do.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, he could say it.
[SPEAKER_06]: If you guys wanted to go back and secure the island with the two Corseo ships,
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I've got no command over these guys, though, is the only thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not in the Navy, I'm not military.
[SPEAKER_02]: So wait a minute, this solves a problem.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, but as an agent...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gotta get back.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, so he can go back.
[SPEAKER_06]: You gotta get him back.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think everyone here that was sent on the mission, Paul has to report to somebody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge has to report to somebody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Merrick has to report to somebody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Jude has to report to somebody.
[SPEAKER_04]: The two of you need to drink beers in the pub.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, we do.
[SPEAKER_03]: And SingSong.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the same person as me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we all go back, we can be back with a day.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we're all gonna go back?
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's all go back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Take a long rest when we get back.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we'll meet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm ready to burn some shit down.
[SPEAKER_03]: As gung-po as I am about taking the island back, I don't think...
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not really in a position where we could be making too many... Yeah, actually, that wasn't even our mission.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, no, it's not.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to go back and talk to Jamis.
[SPEAKER_03]: We've got everything we know.
[SPEAKER_02]: This could just be military.
[SPEAKER_00]: It could be you guys going back out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: As I was going to say, our mission was to make sure that the helm was okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, that's what I was saying.
[SPEAKER_06]: These guys were, like, trying to make sure you're okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we gotta get everybody back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was sent as a bodyguard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everybody goes back.
[SPEAKER_01]: By the time we get back, Jude, now I'll be at bodyguard work.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be ready to hit the freaking bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I was not sent for any assassination.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was sent as a bodyguard and to report back on whatever our findings were.
[SPEAKER_02]: The mystery of the island.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so on the ships, you guys get back to Monmurg by 3 p.m. and I'm gonna call this
[SPEAKER_04]: And, um,